when I see the young guys coming up the
guys with the blue check mark and the
Rolex posing in front of the lambo they
rented for the day those people only
impress people who don't know what
players look like like we all know that
that guy is not a player because the
guys who are players at their age in 20
maybe 30s whatever like right at that
stage like they're hungry they're
Savages and they're in the grind and
they're doing the work of giving first
to as many people as they can overd
delivering knowing that that Goodwill
will compound that single skill has
served me so well because that's how
I've been able to get into rooms that I
didn't deserve to be in was by just
saying like okay what am I good at that
I can help this guy out with